bonjour nous sommes le vendredi 12
février voici les titres que nous allons
développer au cours de la prochaine demi
heure coup d'envoi de la semaine de
l'emploi à saint quentin en yvelines
avec aujourd'hui à guyancourt un forum
des formations aux métiers
comme chaque vendredi lors de la seconde
partie de cette édition retour sur les
faits marquants de l'actualité depuis le
début de la semaine des déplacements de
la ministre de l'écologie et du
secrétaire d'état chargé des transports
au médecin des yvelines qui annonce
passer dorénavant aux 35 heures nous en
parlons à tout à l'heure dans
l'essentiel de la semaine en seconde
partie de ce journal et puis elle
défense de michel platini et réouverture
du dossier de bernard tapie sur
l'arbitrage dans l'affairé adidas thomas
clay avocat et professeur de droit à
l'université de versailles saint quentin
est l'invité de cette édition la semaine
de l'emploi c'est donc à partir
d'aujourd'hui et jusqu'au 19 février 20e
édition de cette opération qui entend
coller au mieux aux attentes des
candidats et des employeurs des
entreprises première opération ce
vendredi avec un forum des formations à
guyancourt florane parfait près de 40
exposants présents pour la 24e édition
du forum des formations aux métiers
si les secteurs qui recrutent cherche à
attirer les collégiens prêt à rentrer
rapidement dans le monde du travail
c'est le cas de l'école française de la
gastronomie ferrandi située à jouy en
josas
elles forment aux métiers de la
restauration
enquête
cette voie là bonne journée au forum
c'est un métier qui a besoin de beaucoup
beaucoup de jeunes dans le sens où on a
beaucoup d'offres d'emploi sur la région
parisienne
un moyen pour les acteurs des formations
courtes et professionnalisantes de
rencontrer peut-être leurs futurs élèves
et de se faire connaître il ya beaucoup
de ses fans de centres de formation des
lycées professionnels qui représentent
les métiers de la bouche le métier en
lien avec l'automobile
il ya aussi des représentants de la
sécurité désarmés la nouveauté de cette
année c'est la place du secteur de la
sécurité sur le forum armées de terre de
l'air la marine et pour la première fois
de la police nationale et municipale
vous savez qu'au mieux les événements
récemment il ya plus en plus besoin de
sécurité de présence policière
sur le terrain donc
effectivement il ya une réelle demande
une explosion des demandes d'ailleurs
pour les concours d accès à la police je
pense que ça renforcer ou l envie de
chez certains jeunes de s'engager
s'impliquer dans tout ce qui est le
secourisme l'armée la police solution
notant que dans plus de policiers le
contexte va pas aller en s'arrangeant
concours c ap ou alternance tous les
moyens d'accéder aux différents métiers
sont expliqués aux jeunes saint
quentinois dans le pavillon
waldeck-rousseau les parents sont
également les bienvenus programme
complet de cette 20e semaine de l'emploi
sur le site de l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines je reçois donc à
présent thomas clay bonsoir on soit un
professeur agrégé de droit privé
vice-président de l'université de
versailles-saint-quentin g10 avocat un
petit peu rapidement total je ne suis
pas et je fais la correction vous êtes
ce doyen honoraire de la faculté de
droit et de sciences politiques
spécialiste de l'arbitrage vous
intervenez régulièrement dans les médias
sur deux dossiers principalement la
faire tapis et puis aussi sur le dossier
de michel platini membres de son équipe
de défense le 15 février
il va se rendre d'ailleurs michel
platini à l'audience de la commission de
recours de la fifa qui étudiera son
appel contre sa suspension de huit ans
je sais que vous pouvez en dire peu
surtout que nous sommes à quelques jours
de ce recours de cette demande
mais quel est son état d'esprit et déjà
michel platini écoutez je suis très
embarrassé effectivement par votre part
cette question parce que l'audience a
lieu lundi à zurich
c'est là c'est qu'une des audiences dans
un parcours processuel compliqué et donc
on a décidé de ne pas s'exprimer sur le
sujet avant l'audience donc malgré
l'amitié que j'ai pour vous et pour la
chaîne sur ce dossier
l'état d'esprit les gens restent
évidemment ce coffret on puisqu'il n'a
rien à se reprocher michel platini dans
cette affaire la pression s'est un peu
desserré depuis que il a annoncé qu'il
n'était pas candidat et je reste moi
persuadé que l'objectif était d'éviter
qu'il soit candidat à la présidence de
la fifa voilà donc il ya un parcours
processuel juridictionnelle la seriat la
commission de recours à la fifa donc on
est encore en quelque sorte en train de
jouer à l'extérieur sur terrain adverse
puisqu'on joue à la fifa contre la fisa
et puis si la décision de recours est
défavorable nous irons ensuite devant
une juridiction indépendante et
impartiale qui s'appelle le tribunal
arbitral bina c'est qu'une étape wallace
est rentrée de son dossier parce qu'on
l'a compris vous pouvez pas vous vous
exprimez dessus mais qu'on comprenne le
processus pour l'instant et c'est devant
la fifa et après il ya une possibilité
encore de recours d'appel à l'extérieur
absolument devant une juridiction
indépendante une autre affaire celle ci
vous pouvez en parler plus c'est celle
de bernard tapie début décembre il est
condamné en appel à rendre les 405
millions d'euros qu'il avait obtenu dans
l'aber dans la
vitrage dans la sphère adidas la revente
d'adidas comment vous avez accueilli
cette décision vous qui étiez à
l'origine on va dire en tout cas un des
premiers à avoir donné l'alerté
oui je remercie de cette précision parce
que vous rapprocher de dossiers mais mon
rôle n'est pas du tout de même dans les
deux dossiers
autant je suis un des conseils de michel
platini je le défends dansante dans
cette affaire autant l'égard de bernard
tapie je n'ai aucun rôle ni dans la
défense et encore moins dans le jerry
dire dans l' attaque de bernard tapie
j'ai fait j'ai eu un rôle d'aiguillon
j'ai dénoncé cette cet arbitrage parce
que c'est fait c'est vrai qu'il tombait
dans mon champ de spécialité et je les
dénonce aider dès le début dès qu'on a
connus la sainte ans en juillet 2008
donc inlassablement j'ai considéré que
ce qu'on nous racontait ne ressemblait
pas un véritable arbitrage ça
ressemblait à un arrangement et il se
trouve que les enquêtes ont été
diligentées que ce soit au tribunal au
pôle financier à paris que ce soit à la
colo discipline budgétaire soit
l'ensemble des juridictions qui sont
prononcés on a appris tellement de
choses au fur et à mesure que finalement
les les intuitions du début ont été
confirmés alors bernard tapie a mal pris
un certain nombre de déclarations que
j'ai fait dans la presse et en
particulier quand j'avais 10 en 2011
qu'il semblait au vu du rapport de la
cour des comptes que cet arbitrage était
peut-être frauduleuse donc vers l'ère
tapie m'avait attaqué en diffamation ce
pourquoi je l'avais d'ailleurs fait
condamner finalement s'aperçoit quoi
deux décisions de la cour d'appel de
paris en 2015 lune le 17 février qui
reconnaît la fraude incontestablement
et puis l'une le 3 décembre à laquelle
vous venez de faire référence qui
demande à bernard tapie de rendre
l'intégralité des sommes qu'il a touchés
j'aurais juste faire une remarque sur
cette affaire parce qu'on a appris
également que pour l'instant rien
n'avait été remboursé le 30 novembre
trois jours justement avant l arrêt de
la cour d'appel qui allait le condamner
à rembourser il a obtenu que ces
sociétés soient placées en procédure de
sauvegarde
c'est donc que ça gèle la situation
pendant six mois rien à rembourser
aujourd'hui
pour l'instant les procédures de
recouvrement sont effectivement bloquées
par cette ce stratagème de dernière
minute in extremis mais qui ne trompent
pas et contre lequel d'ailleurs je crois
que le cdr c'est à dire l'état a fait
appel
mais ce n'est pas parce que rien n'est
remboursé aujourd'hui que rien ne sera
remboursé à terme je suis même convaincu
exactement du contraire d'autant que
dans le cadre de la procédure pénale
cette fois ci il ya un certain nombre de
saisies conservatoires qui ont été
pratiqués sur des éléments du patrimoine
de bernard tapie
et puis quand bien même mère un tapis
aurait-il voulu distraire de son
patrimoine un certain nombre d'éléments
pour ne pas payer sa dette à terme cela
pourrait être considéré comme une
organisation frauduleuse d'insolvabilité
de laquelle il devrait aussi rendre des
comptes à terme je les ai toujours dit
il devra rembourser
même si on imagine mal on l'imaginé mal
faire un chèque de 405 millions d'euros
il ya eu un chèque dans l'autre sens
donc encore faut-il que l'argent soit
toujours là mais l'argent il est quelque
part
voilà et je pense qu'aujourd'hui les
services de l'état savent où se trouve
cet art une question sur la procédure
justement des recours sont encore
possible ou l'affairé définitivement
alors il y a deux pourvois en cassation
qui sont en cours contre les 2 array
lincs donc l'arrêt du 17 février l'autre
l'arrêt du 3 décembre c'est la procédure
classique après des arrêts d'appel on
peut faire des pourvois en cassation
je vous dirai sans vouloir évidemment
préjugés mais comme jusqu'à présent je
me suis jamais trompé que je ne vois pas
comment ces recours ces pourvois
pourrait aboutir et pourrait casser ces
deux décisions de cour d'appel qui sont
il faut le rappeler extraordinairement
bien motivés minitieusement rédigé et on
sent que les juges ont pesé au trébuchet
la rédaction de leurs arguments de leur
fondement juridique dans ces deux
décisions donc la faire tapis est
terminée sur le plan civil pour moi
déterminer comment on peut expliquer que
ça a été si long et qui est autant de
rebondissements le la durée de la
procédure
elle tient pour l'essentiel aux
interventions
j'allais dire dilatoire en tout cas à
tout ce qu'a fait bernard tapie pour que
ça dure
bernard tapie ou d'ailleurs le
gouvernement entre 2007 et 2012
la sentence arbitrale elle est rendue en
juillet 2008
d'accord dès juillet 2008 on sent qu'il
se passe quelque chose de pas clair
or la saisine de contre la sentence
devant la cour d'appel
elle se fait en mai 2013 donc a
probablement un an à peu près un an qui
est imputable au gouvernement
d'alternance
mais il y en a quatre préalables qui
sont imputables au gouvernement
intérieur donc ça c'est bon puis après
il ya les quinze ans antérieures entre
93 et 2008 sur la procédure elle-même
mais tout ça a été ralentie par les
manoeuvres marc tapis on a quand même
l'impression qu'il ya un jeu politique
en fonction des couleurs politiques et
des gouvernements en place derrière elle
ce que la justice a travaillé de manière
sereine indépendante à la justice
judiciaire a travaillé de manière
sereine et indépendante
la justice arbitrale manifestement non
alors au gré des alternances oui dans
l'art tapie est un personnage qui a
fasciné qui fascine encore à droite
comme à gauche et d'ailleurs qui peut
dire quel est le positionnement
politique de bernard tapie aujourd'hui
quant à justin 21 candidats pour 2020
lancera en tête mais ça c'est vraiment
vérifié ses intentions pour 2017
mais moi j'ai jamais pensé que c'était
un dossier politique c'est à dire que
l'annulation de la sentence j'ai pas
pensé que c'était une poursuite d'un
objectif politique pour déstabiliser en
gros sarkozy et sa clique
en cette instrumentalisation d'une
procédure qui fonctionne bien et dont
versailles est en quelque sorte
l'épicentre scientifique puisque c'est à
l'université de versailles qu'il ya le
plus gros laboratoires de droit de
l'arbitrage donc l'instrumentalisation
de cette procédure au profit de bernard
tapie physiquement et moi qui suis un
défenseur de l'arbitrage et non pas un
attaquant dans l'art tapis j'ai voulu
dire que l'arbitrage n'était pas fait
pour ça même si je leur précise
puisqu'on n'a pas dit aujourd'hui on
l'avait déjà dit par le passé vous êtes
proche du parti socialiste
ah oui je suis proche du parti
socialiste un riche proche du parti
socialiste ont pris feu mais on peut
dire ça oui je suis surtout membre de la
haute autorité du parti socialiste voilà
donc c'est un jeu à la fois proche et en
même temps indépendant juste pour
bernard tapie vous le voyez se présenter
à la présidentielle 2017 imagine 4 5% je
veux pas me prononcer sur ces sujets
est-ce qu'il se présentera à l'élection
nationale ou
localement à marseille j'en sais rien je
vais profiter de votre présence pour
évoquer un dernier sujet vous avez
rejoint l'équipe de thierry mandon
c'était à l'été dernier le secrétaire
d'état à l'enseignement supérieur à la
recherche
comment ça se passe actuellement alors
là encore c'est les sujets dont on n'a
pas le droit de parler quand on est
conseiller je suis conseiller personnel
de thierry mandon et l'usagé veut que
des conseillers de cabinets n'est pas le
droit de parler de ce qu'ils font dans
le cabinet d'ailleurs on peut le
comprendre un ministre il est là pour ça
donc si vous me demandez comment ça se
passe moi je vous dirais que c'est un
plaisir de travailler avec ce ministre
et vous avez un peu moins de temps pour
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines
j'ai fait que j'ai fait de de répartir
montant de façon à continuer ma mission
première est mon vrai métier qu'est
l'enseignement et la recherche dans
cette université est d'ailleurs en
quittant ce plateau je vais aller faire
court et je vous laisse aller faire pour
les étudiants vous attendent merci
thomas clay professeur agrégé de droit
privé on a dit vice président de l'uwe
excuse doyen honoraire de cette faculté
de droit et de sciences politiques merci
à vous bien servi le journal se poursuit
et avant comme chaque vendredi de
revenir sur l'actualité de la semaine un
point sur celle du jour tout autre sujet
le parc de thoiry qui est en pleine
effervescence après quatre mois de repos
les animaux du zoo attendent l'arrivée
des visiteurs la réouverture est
programmée pour ce week end
quatre cent mille personnes l'année
dernière se sont rendus sur ce site le
point sur la nouvelle saison qui va
débuter avec michael et demi d'euros et
patrick jacques de dixmude à sa
connaissance un peu abrupte
ce rire ne devrait pas passer inaperçu
dans les allées du parc zoologique de
thoiry la structure qui rouvre ses
portes ce samedi 13 février accueille
pour cette nouvelle saison 4e d'acheter
le groupe composé de deux mâles et deux
femelles est installé dans un domaine de
1500 mètres carrés au niveau des lions
dans le parc à pied un tunnel de verre
de 17 mètres de long a été construit
car son déni at war et connaissent le
principe du tunnel de verre aux lions et
au team où on est enterrée dans le sol à
environ un mètre
ce qui fait qu'on est plus rare que les
prédateurs et on est en totale immersion
parce que on traverse au milieu de ce
tunnel de verre que vous voyez et le yen
approche le tunnel et on est chez elle
les visiteurs pourront également
découvrir les dole cette espèce venue
d'inde a été installé dans l'ancien
enclos des loups c'est un canidé qui
vient d'asie qui se situe quelque part
entre le chacal et le loup et qui vit en
meute comme un loup avec un couple
reproducteur comme un lourd un mâle
alpha une femelle alpha et qui vit en
meute assez importante et donc ici nous
on a un groupe de dix sept individus en
2015 le parc zoologique de thoiry a
connu une année record avec plus de 450
mille visiteurs un chiffre qui lui
permet de se classer à la troisième
place des sites touristiques les plus
visités en ile-de-france en dehors de
paris
loisirs nous sommes toujours les
archives départementales des yvelines
organise depuis décembre des ateliers de
généalogie les gêner lab un rendez vous
mensuel animé par un spécialiste du
domaine traité pour présenter les
ressources internes est ce nécessaire à
ces différentes recherches tels que
geneanet genealogie.com ou encore et
gallica moyen efficace pour comprendre
les fonctionnalités de ces sites des
types d'informations qu'ils fournissent
prochain rendez vous le mardi 8 mars 18h
avec une présentation du site mémoire
des hommes détails de ce projet avec
romain dugast c'est le chef de service
aux archives départementales des
yvelines initialement le projet a été
initié avec le cercle géologique de
versailles des yvelines
donc c'est vrai que la géologie est
quelque chose qui passionne le grand
public et c'est un public naturel des
archives départementales donc c'est une
vraie une vraie opportunité pour nous de
satisfaire une partie du public qui
s'intéresse à ces aspects
seconde partie de ce journal et nous
passons à l'essentiel de la semaine le
zapping de l'actualité locale préparé
par pascal josèphe
c'est un premier pas vers un
rapprochement des départements des
yvelines et des hauts-de-seine
le 5 février les conseils départementaux
des deux territoires ont voté pour la
création d'un établissement public de
coopération interdépartementale situé à
vélizy villacoublay
une structure qui selon les deux
présidents devraient permettre des
économies
il n'y a personne d'embauché pour cela
ce sont nos services qui conjointement
travaillent ensemble à la fusion
progressive
près de 300 millions d'euros pour les
réseaux routiers sur l'année 2016 c'est
le campus scientifique et technique de
colas à magny les hameaux qui a choisi
alain vidalies secrétaire d'état pour
l'annoncer très concrètement sert faire
refaire des voix
refaire des de la signalétique refaire
des bordures tout ce qui aujourd'hui
s'appelle l'entretien etc est
indispensable est ce que c'est la vraie
réponse cette question de la déchéance
de la nationalité aux difficultés que
l'on peut rencontrer mir contre le
terrorisme vient bien sûr que non bien
sûr que non
je comprends que certains défendent la
valeur symbolique de cette de cette
mesure
en réalité on n'est pas dans le temps du
symbole on est dans le temps de l'action
et de l'efficacité par rapport à une
menace qui est éminente puisque on a
l'état d'urgence qui la menace du
terrorisme
chantal goya qui était samedi dernier au
théâtre espace coluche de plaisir
pour la première date de sa nouvelle
tournée avec son spectacle les aventures
fantastiques de marie-rose un ensemble
de 14 nouvelles chansons avec même de
tout nouveaux personnages comme un petit
rat qui s'appelle raccourcis des souris
un loup des koalas qui vont emmener
petits et grands à la découverte d'un
tout nouveau décor également celui du
vieux paris
pire
versailles chantiers la guerre n'a
jamais aussi bien porté son nom si elle
a été fondée en 1932 elle n'avait pas
reçu de modification significative
depuis avec actuellement 68 mille
usagers par jour et quasi mille trains
qui passent par ce noeud ferroviaire des
travaux était indispensable
le trafic transilien à croire
régulièrement d'année en année on a de
plus en plus de clients et on avait de
moins en moins de possibilités pour en
termes de confort d'information
voyageurs et surtout pas d'évacuation de
nos clients de bonnes conditions
première réunion publique et première
tuile pour la municipalité de la
verrière la commune proposait samedi
matin une concertation aux habitants
autour de la rénovation du quartier du
bois de l'étang
seulement certains sont loin d'y être
favorable ils craignent de voir les
immeubles détruits sans garantie d'être
relogées sur place dans de nouveaux
programmes du lundi au vendredi dès 13
heures jean michel et son équipe arpente
l'intérieur des trains mais aussi les
quais et les gars cigarettes mendicité
ou traversée des voies
autant de problèmes auxquels les
médiateurs doivent faire face toujours
avec diplomatie
la rose mais généralement à chaque porte
pour éviter les blocages de porte parce
que les gens quand ils arrivent en masse
ils ont tendance à vouloir bloquer
d'efforts pour pouvoir rentrer quand
même donc s'y met en retard toute la
ligne et aujourd'hui c'est acté mercredi
la pmi sera fermée je ne sais même pas
ça c'est ce qui nous est revenue par les
différentes discussions les différents
réseaux que nous avons il nous a été dit
a priori plus de plus de prise de
rendez-vous à partir du 8 février
et il faut faire l'écart il faut que les
services fassent leurs cartons pour le
10 février le 10 février donc demain
dernière permanence
a priori c'est à dire qu'on n'a aucune
information officielle de la part du
département et à saint quentin en
yvelines une cinquantaine de médecins
généralistes à appliquer désormais des
dépassements pour exigence particulière
du patient en dehors des plages horaires
de 9h à 17h un mouvement qui s'apparente
aux 35 heures en réponse au projet de
loi de santé que les médecins condamne
dit souvent que on aidé des salariés la
sécurité sociale on a dit ben si on est
d'essayer de la sécurité sociale à ce
moment là on travaille 35 heures
pour la saint valentin les
établissements des civils ont entamé une
opération à séduction dans l'abbaye des
vaux de cerner la direction joue la
carte historique de repas sont organisés
les 13 et 14 février dans l'ancienne
demeure cistercienne datant du xiième
siècle les couples pour ensuite passer
la nuit dans l'une des cinquante sept
chambres de l'établissement
une recette qui fonctionne depuis dix
ans ce sont à présent les jeunes qui
s'expriment sur l'actualité locale et
nationale comment ont-ils perçu les
informations de ces derniers jours c'est
qu'on se prépare et par william elle
avec les élèves du collège des soldes
guyancourt
ils ont décidé de mettre par exemple la
pharmacie au mieux de l'écrire ph
vous marquez il vous m f me de ph
parce qu'il ya des jeunes qui arrivent
pas allez vous faites quoi ils ont
décidé d'enlever les accents sur les
mots pour plus facile et esso qu'ils ont
du mal à tempête ils ont décidé
d'enlever l'accent circonflexe
moi je trouve que c'est béton fait parce
que parce que du coup et bas après ben
la pub même orthographe du coup et bacon
nous par exemple si on a des enfants on
va essayer de les aider
eh ben ça va être impossible pour nous
parce que on aura la meilleure
photographie
bah moi je pense que ça a un côté c'est
bien parce que comme ça ils n'ont pas
besoin se compliquer la vie et d'un
autre côté je trouve que c'est pas très
bien parce qu'en fait ils vont faire la
route pendant toute leur vie et tout le
monde va redire même si je veux changer
les mois à oui ça s'écrit pas comme ça
et tout pour moi sa bonne bonne idée
parce qu'il ya des gens qui ont
travaillé dur pour pour comprendre et il
ya des gens qu'ils ont travaillé dur
pour comprendre et au moment où l'on
compris il décide d'enlever tout le
reste
là pour moi c'est pas normal moi je dis
c'est aller vers la facilité parce
qu'après si on sait on sait écrire tous
les maux c'est tout faire ben à rennes
je vois pas à quoi ça sert d'apprendre
de nouvelles choses
quand j'ai envie de bien décrire ouais
je mets les accents du tout mais quand
par exemple quand je suis au texte avec
des amis et tous pour dire pourquoi je
mets juste pk ça permet que quand on est
entre amis sur texto au mieux de faire
des phrases trop longue des mots trop
long bah on met en abréviation en fait
d'un côté là
après toute notre vie on va écrire la
faute alors que de l'autre côté ça nous
permet de plus discutés sur en sms danse
et babeth parce que les bornes mais
moins de temps sur les textos doux nom
c'est mieux sur les textos mais on
classe non c'est pas bien c'est bien de
changer les mots pour faciliter mais par
contre quand même essayer de ne pas trop
faire des fautes d'orthographe promet un
mot du programme de radio sensations à
présent nos confrères qui vous propose
ce week-end un hebdo politique avec rama
sall nouvelle jeune conseillère
régionale socialiste de 29 ans ancienne
assistante du député de la 11e
circonscription des yvelines benoît
hamon elle évoquera avec nikola
kirillovitch ces projets l actualité
écouter cet extrait où elle parle du
cumul des mandats
d'après un sondage aux hawks à près de
huit français sur dix voudrait imposer
le non cumul des mandats dans le temps
limitant à demande électif cette
proposition vous semble-t-elle
intéressante
je suis tellement favorable depuis
longtemps par ailleurs je pense que la
politique ça va être un moment qu'on
donne en deçà vie et qu'on doit pas
différemment faire carrière non parce
que par ailleurs c'est pas bon pour la
politique ça ne me gêne plus il ya plus
de renouvellement guider la politique a
besoin régulièrement de souffle nouveau
pour pouvoir continuer à obtenir des
progrès pour pour les citoyens donc
plutôt favorable à l'actualité locale
revient lundi en direct dès 18h sur
notre antenne première rediffusion à 19
heures et aussitôt replay sur le site
www.tv5monde.com voici quelques-uns des
sujets qui seront développés la fin des
soldes d'hiver le bilan est il positif
après un démarrage encourageant à mi
parcours c'était plutôt décevant pour
les commerçants certains pose à nouveau
la question de déplacer les dates des
soldes et puis à plaisir le quartier du
val hibou va avoir ses fraises qu'il ya
un peu plus de deux ans la municipalité
menée par la mer les républicains
joséphine coleman berger avait lancé ce
projet de création d'immenses dessin en
trompe l'oeil
la réalisation sera officialisée
mercredi soir ce sera une première en
ile-de-france et dans quelques instants
après ce journal michael et demi d'euros
pour le 7-8 week end avec les idées
sorties et loisirs pour les prochains
jours c'est la fin de cette édition du
vendredi 12 février
on est vous lundi bon week end